these are misdemeanor marijuana arrests
which you see spiking precipitously in
the 90s we're a Libertarian publication
and so this kind of uh chart is uh you
know alarming to us to say the least and
then
um you know in the in the subsequent
years most States at this point have
legalized cannabis on one level or
another I guess my question for you is
how do you think that has gone so far
terribly
New York City New York State's a case in
point I had the experience when I went
to LA in 2002 California supposedly the
healthiest state in America
I basically had a medical marijuana
clinics where you basically get a
doctor's prescription to go get
marijuana and outside every one of those
clinics you'd see quite a few characters
hanging around hoping to scrounge
marijuana off the people going in with
the prescriptions that uh my prediction
for you I am not a supporter of
marijuana in any way shape or form
except for but it's a medicinal use
because I don't think we so fully
understand its impact on the development
of young people or the day-to-day use
that we're now actually encouraging
in my last year 2016 in New York City uh
marijuana was associated with more
murders than cocaine heroin and the
other drugs fentanyl had just begun to
occur during that time what what does
that mean to say Associated that there
was marijuana on the scene crime
associated with uh people trying to rip
off marijuana dealing that it just was
always found at the scenes of so many of
these crimes but you're you're not
saying it was I mean it's not like
during prohibition where you know uh Al
Capone and Bugsy Moran were fighting it
out over booze I mean it's not marijuana
isn't causing it it's just it's a lot of
it a lot of people are using it a lot of
it was in fact with uh criminals
basically going after each other to Rob
each other for the monies that it
generates Rob each other off control of
the sale of it which was because it was
illegal to sell it uh uh it's still
illegal in some instances it might not
part of the issue it is so confusing as
to uh
how do you get it right now there's 1500
illegals locations in New York to buy it
there are three legal locations so the
billions of dollars of tax revenue that
the state claims it's going to get
they're not going to get it meanwhile
that's bad bureaucracy but I mean it's a
bureaucracy isn't that and I mean the
rollout has certainly been botched of
legal marijuana but if uh isn't this a
point in case where it's not marijuana
people don't smoke marijuana and they've
become I've got to kill somebody if
anything they tend to become pretty
chill but by making it legal and putting
it into storefronts like you know nobody
nobody really gets uh you know you don't
see a lot of murders around the uh Black
Market sale of booze anymore like you
did during prohibition wouldn't
legalizing it alleviate much of the
crime that you're talking about if it
had been done properly it was not done
properly in California it's being done
horrifically poorly here in New York
State uh even the idea of restricting
these legal marijuana stores to people
who had been convicted of crimes
involving marijuana so it sets a uh a
bad example in some respects if you will
that because you were involved in the
illegal sale in the past you now go to
the front of the line to try to sell it
legally now the issue here is so you if
I I just dilate on that a little bit you
you don't believe in the idea of of of
of a good drug dealer essentially
supporter of the legalization of
marijuana other than I'm a strong
believer and it's used for medicinal
purposes I think it's use in a regular
way over time we just don't know there's
a lot of studies out there that are
still being studied uh so that this rush
to legalize most of the rush to legalize
by our politicians uh it's twofold one
to prevent uh the potential creation of
criminal records which is a reasonable
uh rationale but the other is to uh
generate money and generating the money
this is where it's going to fall down
because there's not a state that's
legalized that's ever recognized the
money that they thought they were going
to get why because yeah that well I I'm
sure we will I think we'll have to agree
to disagree on some of this certainly we
will definitely disagree on marijuana
yeah and other drugs and other drugs and
or currently illegal drugs you you are
against you know I I mean because one of
our arguments would be when you make the
sale uh the production and the sale of
these things legal you take the crime
away from it in the same exactly in the
same way
you take some of the crime away because
the illegal Market is still out there
you think the Mexican cartels are
basically gotten out of the business of
uh trying to control the marijuana
they're very busy now with fentanyl
naturally but the idea is there's a way
around that too legalize it but the
black market still generates a
significant amount of the crime in the
sense and also the fact that it's still
a cash business and there's the other
issue at the federal level yeah it's
still illegal so you basically have to
take cash because you effectively can't
use the banks so as uh mayor Adams has
complained about in New York City I
haven't seen the specific figures but
the concern about all these illegal
marijuana shops with all this cash on
hand because become targets for
robberies we'll see how that goes over
time well again there's a clear fix to
that we will have you back after drugs
are actually legal and we see that crime
disappears around the drug traffic as
well
what you're going to end then see is
that all these movies about zombies
wandering the streets yeah yeah yeah
let's hope they'll be happy and peaceful
hey that's an excerpt from our reason
live stream with Bill Bratton who was
New York City's top cop he also worked
in LA and oversaw dramatic decreases in
crime we talked about what's going on
now what worked in the past what might
work in the future and how do you square
all of that with the need for civil
liberties if you want to watch the whole
video check it out
and if you want to check out our recent
live streams we do them every Thursday
at Zach weismiller and I at 1 pm eastern
time go to reason.com and check us out